皆さんこんにちは
[音楽]
よろしくお願いいたします
私は現在今後大阪から車で
JRでも1時間半くらいの
東は映画南はロシアの北浜は
農作物に囲まれれば左側といういわゆる
地域からやってまいりました
今
1年記を運営しておりまして
おりました
1つは自分が選べることが生まれ育って
そのままで
働いていうこともありますけれども
これから何を目指しそして何をしようとし
ているそういったところをお話を聞いて
いただきたいと思いますよろしくお願い
しますまずは
皆さん南山城村という名前地域を聞かれた
ことありますか
本当に誰もあまり知られてない地域です
お茶に
原料を供給しているこちらのサービスでし
てお
茶を作っているし
だいたい
ユーチューバーが
新規です
ペットボトルのお茶とかいろんなペーパー
はこちら
そして
いると思いますけれどもそういったお茶の
中には
宇治抹茶っていうその中には
多分皆さんも知らず知らずのうちに入れ
られるんだろうと呼んでいただいてそう
いう風に思います
なぜその
村が知られてないかっていうのはそのうち
の
ブランドが本当に大きすぎて
いたということもありますけれども
その大きなブランドに
あるんですが
今の
急性お茶を飲むことが少なくなりました
いろいろと全国で日本で若い方がちょっと
おしゃれなカフェをされてます
か
そういう人たちにお茶をお話ししていく
かっていうことを
してるんですけどもそういうその生活の
スタイルが変わっていっていうことで
やはりこちらの消費が
子供たちに
ちゃんと勉強しないとうちたくないといけ
ないよ
いけないよみたいで言われてまして本当に
人口減少とか
自己負担になってる
2014年
消滅可能性都市
っていうことを聞かれたことがあると思い
ますこれは日本創生会議という
あたりが
女性の
子供を産む世代の人たちの
流出が大きいところそういうところも
比較して南山城村はなんと全国で17番目
に
調律するという自治体に
守れている
そういうところが
行政に例えば
とかしていかないといけないするんです
けども僕は
それまでいろいろとフリー
画像を覚えていろんなことをやってまして
その中でいろんなこう手応えを感じていた
ので
少しずつですけれども明るい暮らし
それでこの光みたいなことが見えてきまし
たなのでそういうその
張られたレベルに
必要
的になるわけでもなく
これからどういうことをやっていくという
ところをいろんなことであるとき
という
専門部署家族部署ですね
いろいろのそういうミッション
与えられていくわけですけれども今まで
寮生が4000万の国の中でやっていた
だけではなくて
横断的にそれこそその
産業のこともあったり広く
[音楽]
与えられます
配合利用
その場合は新しい
施設小学校
で残った
俳句をどう使うか
結構思い入れができる
そして
売れないお茶をどういう風に言っていくの
か
お茶を触るといろんな人の
クラブ
には
そういうことを少しずつですけども
メディアデータ
[音楽]
の取り組みの一つにつながっているわけ
です
ね
あいつの自信はどこから来てるんやろとか
あいつのとかそういう風なことをされてだ
から
この日もいろんなことやりました
仕事は
ないじゃないか
いろんなことやってきました
[音楽]
役者の机でパソコンでこちらのネット
ショップみたいなことをやっててで本当に
こうあのー
工場でいろいろ行ったりとかそういうこと
されるんです
何も変えられないそういう問題意識の中で
ちょっとねここから見たらその枠に始まっ
てるんですけども
紅茶を作るんですけれども本当に色々と
自分で
自己資金を家族の会社で突っ込んでたり
そういうことをやっていくんですけれども
その中で
やっぱり今まで
こちらの流通って一旦
収穫したの
翌月にはお金になる
形で
本当に
現金が売れないと現金にならないっていう
ことで
ある日僕が不正をして
勝利があるから他に
そういうことをやってきましたなので
収益っていうのをただ中が入れられる
風なことを考えているわけです今ペーカン
ライナー
に以上
ご家族に来られたりその
統計的には80万人
ということでございます
見ていただいてますけれどもこういう山の
中で何もないわざわざその来ることでは
ない地域に
人口が1500人しかいないのに
それは本当に僕も手話が
笑うこと
は全国に1200億円
ことによって
少しで
収入をして
いるそういうことを
投げかけて
みたです
自分たちは作るのができるけど
やろうでやったのか
本当に
技術を習得すれば
プロモーションしたり営業したり
お金が140万ぐらい
して今の配信したんですけどそういうその
農家さんが動きやすい
ですけどもそういうところをどういう風に
こう回していっていうところをすごく
横領の
噂も立てられながら
自分の中で学んできたところです
でそういうその
国をどう作るかというところを
そうですね
そうした時にじゃあ
その計画
を作るんですけども
誰でやるのかっていうところまで
突き詰めて計画を作る作っていく設定ほぼ
ないです
市民が
誰なのか
そういうことが
お金が支払われないそういうところをどう
いうふうに出していくのかということを
そうですね
できるだけ迷惑をかけない
そして
そのお金の流れを作っていくそれ
でした
時に
最初はね僕もやめてやるつもりは全く
なかったんですけども
視察に行った先の
今僕が師匠と会おう
職員が来て
使ってないです
」って言われました
いろいろの見学をお話してる時に
役場にいたら3年もかかるし一応
そんなものについてっていうことは言われ
ました
6年前
をするわけです
けどに
販売されるようになりまし
た
最大で1日4,4
隠れた
藤田の影に隠れてきたエネルギー
をスポットライト
を編み出し
ていろんな自治体からも
視察に福島君ですけども
少ないよりもその小さな範囲の中で
そういうプレイヤーが言ったかどうかって
いうのが非常に問題でした
重要になる
自分がやって本当に良かったかどうかと
いうのは
僕が覚悟をしたことを払うことで自分なり
の課題が見えてきました
誰得なのかどうやっていくのかその
課題に
解決しているように自分はどう動くのか
足りてないところ誰にやってもらうのか誰
かそういうことを
課題として
まだまだ
課題はありますけれどもそうして
腹を作ったからこそその人たち
させていただいている
お客様をいただくお客様とかそういった
方々が共感していただいて
ここまで行きました
自分一人がではできないよとかその
距離が
払うことで本当に動くことがそういうこと
がよくはない人口減少は日本人によって
社会現象です
本当にその前の中でどういう風に機能させ
ていく
かかっていくかっていうのが課題であると
いうふうに
私は
地元の方法を卒業してすぐ帰りました
ブランド思考で仕事にしてないそれだけの
思いで
その特別なトレーニングを受けてきたわけ
でも勉強してたわけでもないんですがその
思いだけでやっていました
けども
自分たちで足元を付け直して
掘り起こしてきたもの
ですもともとご覧いただきます
そういった象徴でもあると
思いますコミュニティをどういうふうに
これからもお繋い
希望を
救えることを体験したからこそ
感じていくことがございます
我々の
企業理念は
出現する
それからその
そういうその
必要なことをつないでいくか
そういうその一人一人の
覚悟でコミュニティーを
その仕組みづくりができるんじゃないかと
いうことを思っています
我々に必要なことを
嫌いそれによってバラの人が
琉球協議していくそういった仕組みづくり
金銭的な資本というよりも動物的
そういった正しいと思うことを
がつながりを持って
そういうことを取り組む人たちが
ホールディングスのような形でカレー配列
につなげていくそういう社会を地域全体で
作っていきたいなそういうことをしており
ます以上ですありがとうございました
[拍手]